una función de la cual hablaré en
términos un poco abstractos en esta
ocasión es algo una función es algo que
va a recibir una entrada
entrada
va a trabajar con esa entrada la va a
manipular y con base en la naturaleza de
esta entrada va a generar o va a
entregar cierta salida
veamos un ejemplo de una función voy a
escribirla como f de x por lo general x
es la variable más usada para expresar
el valor de entrada de una función así
como f tiende a ser el nombre de función
más usado aunque veremos que también se
usan otros nombres para expresar
funciones vamos a definir esta función f
x como x al cuadrado sí
x spas
spar o x5
y x es impar
en paz
esto lo expresamos así con esta llave
cita qué sucederá si ponemos dos como
entradas para esa función
esto es expresas de la siguiente manera
efe aquí pongo la entrada en este caso
es 2 y en cada lugar que veamos la
variable x la vamos a reemplazar por
este 2 en este caso si dos spas
tendremos dos al cuadrado si dos es
impar
tendremos dos más cinco bueno sabemos
que dos spas así que aplicar a este caso
2 al cuadrado si dos espacio esto es
igual 2 al cuadrado es 4 así que la
salida para esta función cuando la
entrada es dos es cuatro ahora cuál será
el resultado si mi entrada para esta
función es un 3 de nuevo este 3 va a
sustituir cada equis que yo vea aquí en
esta función
3 al cuadrados y 3 es par o tres más 53
es impar bueno como 13 sin par va a
aplicar esta 35 así que la función
cuando la entrada es 3 el resultado va a
ser igual a 85 más 38 y ustedes me
pueden decir oye pues esto está muy bien
es una forma interesante de usar esto
para encontrar números pero eso también
puedo hacerlo con lo que ya conozco de
ecuaciones tradicionales que puedo hacer
con las funciones que no puedo hacer con
lo que yo ya conozco bueno ustedes
pueden hacer una función como la
siguiente
mi función se llama h y la variable de
entrada le llamo
y esta función es el próximo número o el
siguiente número el siguiente número
número
que comience
comience
con la misma letra la misma
y la letra
la variable a esta variable de entrada
cuál sería el valor de h 2
h 22 es mi variable de entrada o mi
número de entrada 2 comienza con ver
cuál es el número más grande de 2 que
comienza con b 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10
comienza con ver entonces el resultado
de esta función es 10 ahora cuál será el
valor de hd 8
8 comienza con un número mayor que 8
también comienza con un 8 9 10 11 11
también comienza color esto es igual a
11 como ven con las funciones podemos
hacer cosas muy locas aunque no todas
las funciones tienen que ser tan
extrañas ustedes ya han trabajado con
funciones ya han visto cosas como ye
igual a x + 1
esto puede verse como una función
podemos poner que es igual a una función
de x
que es igual a x + 1
si yo quiero ver el resultado de esta
función cuando x es cero
efe de cero
puede ser o más o no es uno si yo quiero
ver el resultado de esta función cuando
tenemos de entrada dos puede ser a 213
el resultado es 3 esto ya lo han hecho
ustedes con tablas como ésta
voy a dibujar una tabla que más o menos
derechita aquí
esta tabla de dos columnas aquí pongo el
valor de x que se le entrada y aquí el
resultado de salida por ejemplo aquí
tenemos que nuestro valor de entrada
cero daba como resultado un 1 y el valor
de entrada 2 daba como resultado 3 y
ustedes me pueden preguntar bueno cuál
es el punto de usar esta anotación pues
esto nos ayuda a pensar al respecto en
términos más generales y comprender que
una función va a tomar una entrada en
este caso esta es mi entrada la equis y
trabaja con ella en este caso pues le
agrega un 1 y produce una salida lo
incrementa en 1 como vemos en la tabla
ahora veamos lo que no es una función y
dijimos que una función es algo que toma
una entrada y produce una sola salida
para dicha entrada por ejemplo vamos a
ver una relación gráficamente vamos a
dibujar aquí unos ejes voy
aquí unos ejes coordinados aquí más o
menos así y así
y lo que voy a hacer es dibujar una
circunferencia con radio 2 y voy a usar
las herramientas que tengo aquí para
dibujar esta circunferencia que se ve a
voluntad con el centro en el eje
voy a tratar de hacerlo más parejito más
o menos ahí está de radio 2 la ecuación
de esta circunferencia de este círculo
es x cuadrada más que cuadrada
igual al radio al cuadrado y el radio es
2 así que es igual a 4 la pregunta es
esta relación entre xy es una función
aquí a la gráfica están todos los
valores posibles de esta ecuación y
podemos ver que esto no es una función
tomemos cualquier valor de x no sé se me
ocurre vamos a tomar no sé x igual a 1
aquí uno para este x hay dos valores en
el que va aquí hacia arriba
este que llega acá y este hacia abajo
como podemos ver si lo sustituimos aquí
en la fórmula vamos a despejar y vamos a
restar x cuadrada en ambos lados de esta
ecuación me voy a quedar ya cuadrada
igual a 4 - x cuadrado
y para obtener el valor de que tengo que
sacar la raíz cuadrada de todo esto de
acá
la raíz cuadrada de 4 - x
ahora esta raíz cuadrada puede tener dos
valores dos raíces una positiva y otra
negativa si sustituimos aquí el valor de
x por 1 esto es 4 menos 1 al cuadrado 4
- 1 es 3 lleva a ser igual a la raíz de
la raíz de 3 pero puede ser la raíz
positiva o la raíz negativa y de hecho
aquí lo vemos la raíz positiva está en
este valor positivo de iu y la raíz de
negativa está aquí en esta parte del eje
y entonces en este caso tenemos una
entrada que es nuestra equis o nuestro 1
pasa por nuestra cajita que no sabemos
que hay aquí
de esta relación y lo que me está
generando es dos valores me genera la
raíz de 3 positiva y la raíz de 3
negativa
por lo tanto esta no es una función